donc c'est un jour très spécial aujourd'hui
nous jouons le haka la scène
s'ouvre c'est l'équipe de football de ma fille et le
jeu est thaïlandais et nous cherchons à gagner
le match alors nous jouons un coup de feu pour notre
culture polynésienne le haka est très
significatif  jouant Hanuman l'a écrit
puis l'a envoyé en Nouvelle-Zélande afin qu'il
soit béni par nos aînés mon plus grand
rôle ici était de m'assurer que cet
aspect spirituel était intégré aux
personnes à qui j'enseignais ce haka est
très cool et très spécial et je peux  ne
donne pas assez de crédit aux filles pour ce
qu'elles ont fait
danse haka folle c'est l'un de mes
moments préférés dans le film
vous